alain vidalis le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous un moment où l'action du
gouvernement semble durement handicapés
alors que la cote de françois hollande a
atteint un record historique
d'impopularité
l'opposition fait feu de tout bois
volte-face quoi divisions de la majorité
présidentielle mais le parti communiste
français s'y met également à enrayer
critiquent une politique à la petite
semaine
répondre également aux critiques de la
presse qui s'interroge sur une défiance
généralisée et un blocage de l'exécutif
c'est une gageure pour vous que vous
allez devoir relever alain vidalis jean
dupré vaude agence france presse notre
partenaire avec dailymotion et perrine
tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindrons tour à tour au cours de
cette émission d'abord bien sûr
l'écotaxe suspendu par le premier
ministre face à la révolte bretonne
pourquoi ne pas dire que l'on ne verra
pas cette taxe qu'elle ne verra jamais
le jour
ah non je pense que c'est une
surinterprétation ne sais pas ce qui a
été dit suspension ne pas dire
suppression et les vocabulaires en ont
leur importance le principe de cette
taxe reste un bon principe il faut
savoir d'ailleurs que ça vient du
grenelle en 2008 sous l'ancienne
majorité voté à l'époque à l'unanimité
puis dans la loi de finances pour 2008
qui constitue la base juridique de cette
de cette écotaxe après la droite au
pouvoir a mis cette écotaxe en oeuvre
dans des conditions c'est vrai qu'ils
sont pas qu'ils n'étaient pas
satisfaisantes notamment il ya urgence
de la mettre en oeuvre dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas
satisfaisantes le coup de bambou fiscale
si je peux terminer ça ça c'est la
théorie de la droite
ensuite en amiens en a mis en oeuvre ils
ont mis en oeuvre cette taxe en confiant
un opérateur privé qui coûte extrêmement
cher
l'une d'ailleurs des
l'un des problèmes aujourd'hui
sélectionneur est ça coûte 800 millions
que devrait payer comme indemnité à cet
opérateur privé choisi par madame
kosciusko morizet alors qu'elle était
ministre de l'environnement
pour faire simple elle est trouvé seul
800 millions passif alors vers celle des
non nous n'allons pas verser le dédit
l'écotaxe non l'écotaxe n'est pas
supprimée elle est suspendue et nous
allons engager des négociations sur les
conditions de sa mise en oeuvre sur le
principe attendait restons sur le
principe serait ce qu'un consortium
privé et c'est assez inédit dans le pays
soit chargée de collecter cet impôt donc
le ministre stéphane le foll avait dit
que si on arrête ça coûte 800 millions
vont là c'est reporté néanmoins la
société peut peut-être se retourner
contre vous non la société peut pas se
retourner contre nous il n'ya que si on
passait à la suppression qu'il y aurait
3 1 habitées pour l'instant la société
les dans le cadre de l'application du
contrat et déjà elle a déjà un revenu
annuel pour payer les investissements et
les deux portiques visite de patienter
mais nous lui disons de patienter
l'accord helmand mais vous savez alain
vidalis quand vous dites que ça n'est
pas une suppression ça n'est qu'une
suspension vous aller grossir les rangs
des manifestants de la badr aussi rendez
vous voulez pourquoi vous voulez vous
avoir la capacité de dire que ce qu'a
dit le premier ministre ce matin que
c'était suspendu ça voulait dire que
c'était supprimés ils n'ont jamais les
manifestants ils veulent la suppression
bretagne particulièrement il se marie
samedi certains voulaient une
suppression et c'est la plupart certain
nombre d'entre eux j'ai vu les réactions
sont d'accord sur la suspension pour pas
les suspensions c'est pas la suspension
pour dire on verra on la mettra en place
telle qu'elle est plus tard c'est
surtout pas ça c'est de dire puisque les
conditions de mise en oeuvre de quelque
chose que nous avions déjà modifié je
veux dire un mot là-dessus en faveur de
la bretagne qu'en faveur d'un en
bretagne quand on arrive il ya un
abattement qui existent déjà qui est de
25% qui a été prévu pour la bretagne
puisse plus deux autres régions un peu
périphériques
nous l'avons portée nous avons engagé la
négociation nous l'avons porté à 50%
notamment pour la bretagne mais il est
vrai aujourd'hui
et que pourquoi est-ce que ça explose en
bretagne pour une raison très
particulière c'est que c'est la
conjonction entre la mise en oeuvre de
cette taxe sur les poids lourds et la
crise célèbre otage simplement
simplement dans les faits aujourd'hui il
ya un lien entre les deux il n'y a pas
un lien de cause à effet c'est pas l'éco
taxe est à l'origine des difficultés de
la bretagne notamment de la grande
industrie est tout simplement elle
n'existait pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui
toutes les oppositions et vous avez été
très clair effectivement alain vidalis
l'écotaxe n'est pas supprimée alors
qu'en reviendrait-elle le gouvernement a
dit qu'il prendrait le temps de la
négociation pour parvenir à un accord
donc on n'a pas voulu on n'a pas voulu
donner de délai ce sera forcément
quelque chose qui nécessitera plusieurs
mois plusieurs mais je ne peux pas vous
dire et si ça sera deux mois ou 9 mois
ou 10 mois je n'en sais strictement rien
parce que il faut qu'ils aient le temps
de la négociation sur quoi va porter la
négociation vous savez que il ya la
bordée des discussions des précisions
avoir notamment s'agissant ce qu'on
appelle le cabotage c'est-à-dire les
gens qui pour leur travail font 45 40 70
km tous les jours c'est à dire
finalement élargir le champ des
exonérations plus un certain nombre
d'activités professionnelles qui sont
aujourd'hui en crise qui ne l'était
peut-être pas au moment où les quotas
que ça a été a été décidé et dont on va
traiter secteur parce que tu as encore
des étages à l' usine à gaz
écoutez le principe même de l'écotaxe
tel qu'il a été proposé par d'autres
donc je peux le dire à l'aise et on
l'avait votée nous mêmes
c'est un principe et qui est un principe
cohérent c'est à dire yvon si c'est à
dire le luzien l'usure de la route par
le transport routier fait que nous
allons faire payer y compris les camions
étrangers et qui passent sur les routes
françaises de manière à avoir des
revenus qui sont des revenus qui vont
abonder ce qu'on appelle la fidh
c'est-à-dire l' agence de financement
des infrastructures autrement dit l'état
et qui permette picon prix en bretagne
d'avoir le financement de projets
importants routier dans la bretagne dans
la bretagne abreuvera pourquoi il faut
pas leur mettre en cause dans son
principe coeur donc l'ump christian
jacob a tout faux quand il demande la
démission de stéphane le foll mis sur
l'agriculture et qui disait qu' on ne
pouvait pas renoncer à l'écotaxe donc
effectivement on ne renonce pas à
l'écotaxe
vous n'avez nonce pas légaux d'accès
contrat question jacob
c'est une nouvelle preuve de ce
caractère très nuancée de ces propos
alors donc parlons avec vous de
suspension une suspension minable selon
josé bové qui semble dire tout haut ce
que pensent les écologistes on se
souvient d'ailleurs que jean vincent
placé la veille de la décision du
premier ministre avait dit que si le
gouvernement cède il ne faudra pas
s'étonner qu'il n'ait plus aucune
autorité
vous pouvez collectionner les
déclarations de ce type ce qui compte
c'est la réaction aujourd'hui la
réaction des écologistes et notamment de
sénateurs mais il peut y avoir ici ou là
une et lui sait bien que c'est vous
trouverez toujours quelques mois ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la position des
écologistes qui sont des partenaires
dans la majorité et la réaction
aujourd'hui c'est de dire qu'ils restent
favorables à cette taxe poids lourds
mais qu'ils comprennent que dans ces
circonstances aujourd'hui la décision de
suspension qui a été prise est une bonne
décision
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit et notamment ce
qu'a dit un sénateur écologie ce matin à
la réunion à matignon et nationaux mais
voilà il y a eu un déjeuner de la
majorité à midi et ils ont repris
collectivement cette position cette
petite musique toujours en arrière-fond
n'ai pas envie comme 56% des français de
virer les ministres écolo du
gouvernement vous alain vidalis mais
pourquoi voulez-vous enfin cesser ils
font partie du gouvernement c'est un
pacte majoritaire
ils ont soutenu l'élection du président
de la république et personne n'a
l'intention de décider de les virer ils
sont partis intégral est importante et
des ministres écologistes gouvernement
il dit sont tout autre chose m'en reste
dans la révolte fiscale puisque c'est
l'expression utilisée à quoi va servir
la réunion de l'elysée jeudi avec les
huit représentants du football
professionnel parce que l'or là et pas
question de reculer
j'ai envie de dire une nouvelle fois ci
vous allez me reprendre mais n'est pas
ils ont des solutions
il n'est pas question de reculer mais la
politique c'est aussi de la pédagogie il
ils ne sont pas d'accord on l'a bien
compris avec la décision qui a été prise
semble-t-il le projet de grève quelque
chose d'un peu un descendant dans la
situation dans la situation
d'aujourd'hui c'est ce que va leur
revenir et sa langue ce n'est pas ce qui
va leur dire suis pas son porte-parole
mais par contre par contre naturellement
le président de la république quand les
partenaires des socioprofessionnels même
si un désaccord demande à le rencontrer
il affiche sa position qui est pas
circulez ya rien à voir qui est de toute
façon je veux expliquer je veux vous
rencontrer de manière à ce que même si
un désaccord les dialogues sont toujours
maintenues bon d'accord mais la position
et réaffirmer clairement d'accord alors
à propos de françois hollande je vous
parlais du sondage qui montre son record
d'impopularité le monde se demande dans
sa dernière manche est hollande peut-il
encore agir
que répondez vous il agit tous les jours
et il va continuer et il va continuer à
agir
je vois bien dans les commentaires
aujourd'hui il ya une sorte de
commentaires ceux qui ont si c'est à
dire ce président font manquerez m'ont
créé de courage
très honnêtement est-ce qu'il ya eu dans
l'histoire de la république un président
qui a décidé pour l'intérêt de la france
de mener une politique dont il savait
par avance qu'elle était aussi difficile
quand vous rentrez dans un quinquennat
en disant aux français la situation
est-elle je vais vous demander de faire
des efforts c'est à dire de payer des
impôts supplémentaires que je vais être
obligé d'en réduire la déploie dépenses
publiques et pas et souvent moins facile
je veux dire c'est le courage c'est pas
des mots c'est des actes et un président
de la république qui se dit que
l'intérêt supérieur de la france c'est
de mener cette politique je me suis
assez surpris qu'on puisse lui contester
le courage vous savez le courage en
politique il se mesure justement dans la
possibilité et dans la détermination de
prendre des décisions qui sont les
décisions que la situation exige alors
il ya la notion de courage
et d'en parler il ya l'autorité je
l'évoquais à travers des propos anciens
de 24 heures jean vincent placé
il ya aussi la critique qui vise le chef
de l'état on lui dit on lui reproche de
conduire la france un peu comme ils
menaient le le parti socialiste toujours
en ménageant la chèvre et le chou
l'esprit de synthèse ou le souci de la
synthèse mais j'aimerais déjà géante ans
j'entends ce débat et ça nous ramène
aussi à au débat au fond sur le sur le
courage est ce que le courage du
dialogue et de l'apaisement n'est pas
aussi honorable et méritoire que le
pseudo courage de la décision abrupte
circulez ya rien à voir c'est moi le
chef est c'est décidé et on sait très
bien et ça tout ça a été sa personnalité
ça a été sa proposition dans la france
d'aujourd'hui avec tous les antagonismes
qui existe on le sait bien
c'était une situation sociale qui est
difficile on voudrait bien admettre qu
on n est pas les seuls responsables que
ce président que le président françois
hollande décide d'avoir comme marque de
fabrique comme ligne de gouvernance
effectivement de rechercher d'une
manière systématique le dialogue pour ne
pas ajouter de la fracture sociale ou de
la france on a l'impression dialogue
la synthèse entre les différentes
tendances de sa majorité présidentielle
veut c'est pas savez vous savez
au sein même de son camp non je ne vois
pas comment vous pouvez poser cette
affirmation il n'ya pas n'y a pas de
discussion de ce point de vue là c'est
plus quand même il ya quand même des
lignes avant d'envahir aussi si on pense
aux ministres qu'ils défendent certaines
positions humaniste entre guillemets et
le ministre de l'intérieur ayant
présenté la saison
la synthèse a été fait et elle est juste
race un test encore non menace ntesa été
faite mais le most nommons synthèse pèse
de tout son poids
il ya ni perdant ni gagnant si vous
faites allusion à la réforme de la
politique pénale qui sera débattue au
mois d'avril au parlement néanmoins est
ce que vous venez le fait qu'il faudrait
un électrochoc aujourd'hui pour le
pouvoir exécutif
alain vidalies c'est lequel je pense que
l'électrochoc qui viendra dans la
société lorsque les premiers résultats
viendront on est dans la situation
aujourd'hui c'est vrai on a demandé aux
gens des efforts on a une ligne
politique surtout une ligne économique
et qui est clair qu'ils étaient pas
facile qui était courageuse et au nez
dans la période où les premiers
résultats se font en temps ils vont
venir
on le sait bien mais quand vous passez
de 30 mille chômeurs de plus par mois au
mois de janvier à 5000 aujourd'hui pour
les gens ils ont raison c'est toujours
5000 de trop sauf que nous on sait très
bien que cantonné à 5000
c'est plus facile évidemment de passer
ensuite à 0 et à l'inversion que c'était
de notre objectif
donc on a toujours dit que c'était ça la
ligne et je pense que lorsque les
français à fin de l'année verront les
premiers résultats sur ce qu'est
l'objectif majeur du gouvernement mais
qui est aussi leur préoccupation majeure
c'est à dire la question de l'emploi
alors ce sera ça le choc salutaire pour
le gouvernator alors on a quand même
entendu récemment quelques élus
socialistes à critiquer l'action du
gouvernement il ya mais bertrand de la
noue et qui est dit qu'il ne comprenait
pas tout dans la politique qui est suivi
on a vu également qu'elle quelques élus
a claqué la porte du ps comme le
sénateur philippe et snob qui a changé
de groupe du coup il a trouvé refuge
chez les radicaux de gauche avant
d'accueillir jean luc prévost
d'allégeance france-presse parole de
quelques socialistes en rupture avec
mounir soucis après 20 ans au ps david
des roues et a dit stop
le maire de fleury mérogis a rendu sa
carte car à ses yeux un an et demi après
l'élection de françois hollande sur le
plan des réformes le compte n'y est pas
c'est
surtout l'idée que et bien aucun des
engagements électorale faure n'a été
tenue en tout cas ceux qui
structurellement peuvent
fondamentalement changé dans le pays ne
sont pas mises en bon il n'est pas le
seul à avoir claqué la porte la semaine
dernière excédés par la sphère leonarda
le sénateur maire philippe et snow l'a
quitté avec fracas le groupe socialiste
pour rejoindre les radicaux de gauche
un comportement critiqué par marie
noëlle lienemann qui regrettait départ
selon elle pour infléchir la ligne du
parti le combat de ceux menés grâce aux
débats internes quand les choses vont
mal et bien les réflexes individuels
prennent le pas sur l'intérêt général
donc je le regrette mais je pense qu'il
faut regarder le symptôme à son origine
c'est à dire dans une grande un grand
décalage entre ce que fait le
gouvernement et d'espérance de nos
concitoyens singulièrement du peuple de
gauche aujourd'hui sans étiquette david
derrouet ne bénéficiera pas des moyens
du parti socialiste pour mener sa
prochaine campagne municipale
ce qui à ses yeux n'est pas forcément un
inconvénient vu l'impopularité actuelle
de la majorité il beaucoup d'élus locaux
sont comme moi très en colère
d'ailleurs très nombreux sont ceux qui
disent surtout nous mettrons pas le
poing et la rose lors de l'élection
municipale à cette défiance n'inquiète
pas rue de solférino le parti considère
ces départs comme un épiphénomène et
estime que deux cas isolés n'auront
aucun effet boule de neige
voilà à la mairie ces gens les prévôts
de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire pour port par toi qui
nous a rejoint bonsoir jean louis
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur sy fils vos
questions finaliste vous êtes le
ministre des relations avec le parlement
vous êtes bien placé pour écouter les
parlementaires pour pour entendre un peu
toutes les remontées qui peuvent vous
faire le lundi lorsqu'ils reviennent de
leurs circonscriptions de leur
département
alors justement la gronde qui touche
actuellement la france est ce que vous
l'avez entendu elle à la crise sur la
bretagne l'écotaxe l'incohérence un peu
fiscale et toutes les pilules fiscal est
ce que est ce que vous l'avez entendu
est ce que vous êtes en est fait le
relais près du gouvernement
naturellement naturellement dire les
parlementaires quand ils reviennent de
leurs circonscriptions se font l'écho de
ce qui ne va pas et c'est extrêmement
important pour le gouvernement les
réunions d'où des groupes de la majorité
ou leur expression que ce soit
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat sont
évidemment très important c'est pour ça
qu'il ya régulièrement dans la semaine y
compris des réunions avec les les
présidents de groupe les présidents des
deux assemblées pour justement
enregistrer ses positions peut pas dire
le contraire
alors justement là actuellement on a le
texte sur la réforme des retraites qui
au sénat rebond le sénat s'apprête à
voter qu'on l'aï laissé pas une surprise
le ps n'y ait pas la majorité
en revanche assemblée là il ya vie lui
il a manqué dix neuf voix socialistes au
gouvernement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire on est ce
qu'on a frôlé
une espèce de blocage au sein même du ps
dans cette circonstance ou est ce que
les députés n'ont pas été entendus à
cette occasion écoutez la règle en
politique c'est que en démocratie c'est
que c'est la majorité moi je veux bien
comment on passe son temps à parler des
17 qui pensent que l'on peut voter
contre le gouvernement alors qu'on a été
élu avec la même étiquette
je préfère vous parlez des 280 qui
soutiennent la politique du gouvernement
bons essais 17 c'est regrettable c'est
pas cohérent on a droit à ne pas être
d'accord mais on le dit à bord mais dans
tous les cas si on vote aussi important
le vote du budget vos de gaulle
financement de la sécurité sociale et
sur un texte aussi emblématique la
réforme des retraites
je pense qu'il aurait dû effectivement
ne manquer aucune voix des
parlementaires de la majorité et que
c'est tout à fait regrettable ceci dit
ça n'empêche en rien le gouvernement
d'agir
ni dans la quasi totalité des
parlementaires de suivre l'action du
gouvernement 13 points de vue dans le
sujet à un maire qui est donc y rendu sa
carte du ps il sera plus candidat
socialiste à fleury mérogis mais
regardez même à paris anne hidalgo fait
campagne pour les municipales pour la
succession de bertrand delanoë elle l'a
dit elle prend grand soin de se tenir à
distance de l'action du gouvernement sur
le thème ece moi c'est moi qu'elle
comment vous réagissez
mais écoutez quand même ou quand il
candidat à la mairie disent je ne veux
pas rentrer dans un débat qui est un
débat politicien sur pour ou contre
l'action du gouvernement parce que après
après elle sait qu'elle se dit ça va me
plomber fameux plombier m'accorder
d'aller chercher votre interprétation
c'est ce qu'on a compris
oui mais c'est ce que vous avez compris
c'est bien ce que je vais devenir mais
c'est vrai exactement ce n'est pas
forcément la vérité
camer tous les maires mais pas qu'à
cette élection là que c'est quoi une
élection locale
tout le monde sait et c'est une bonne
chose que majorité 1 60% des électeurs
quelles que soient leurs tendances
politiques disent peu ils vont se
prononcer en fonction de l'action locale
c'est spécifique aux élections
municipales
il faudrait quand même être
irresponsable ou être un candidat assez
étonnant de dirhams attendez moi je vais
pas vous parler de la vie puisque vous
prenez l'exemple des parisiens ou de ce
que je vais faire mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est génial ce que fait le
gouvernement pourquoi je suis pas
d'accord je veux dire c'est une réalité
et tous les candidats évidemment essaye
horizon que ça correspond à l'état
d'esprit des appareils électeurs encore
particulier parce que regarder là il ya
une alliance entre les socialistes et
puis les communistes que vous ne venez
pas obtenir sur le plan national sachant
que marie noëlle lienemann qu'on a vu il
ya un instant qu'une brique lama
changement de cap avec l'entrée des
communistes gouvernance et une bosse
c'est une bonne chose qui est une
alliance à paris avec les comices est
pas une alliance d'opportunités c'est
une alliance entre ceux qui ont dirigé
la capitale pendant tant d'années
ensemble qui ont tenu leurs engagements
vis-à-vis des électeurs et qui ont re
signé ce contrat de confiance est une
façon donc de faire de la politique pour
revenir au travail parlementaire vous
avez quand même dans les dossiers un
certain nombre de grands textes de
grandes réformes comme la réforme pénale
la loi sur la famille que vous avez
repoussé après les municipales pourquoi
vous est repoussé à 6 n'a pas la loi sur
la famille n'est pas ne pas passer en
conseil des ministres alors on parle
donc c'est quand même difficile
et puis j'ai parfois aussi obligés de
faire le bad boy vis-à-vis d d d d
autres membres du gouvernement mais
quand vous regardez ce qui va se passer
le parlement arrêtent d'assiéger le 28
février
il ya des textes qui sont passés il ya
plusieurs mois en conseil des ministres
et pas des petits textes la loi
d'orientation agricole suppose que le
débat va être long dans les deux
assemblées
le texte sur le commerce et l'artisanat
importés par sylvia pinel qui est un
texte aussi extrêmement important il
faut dire le texte sur la déontologie
des fonctionnaires puisqu'on a fait pour
les élus au nab
donc on a des textes qui s'en passer il
ya très longtemps plus un certain nombre
de textes dont je ne suis pas
complètement sûr qu'ils seront finis au
31 décès ce que c'est pas parce que vous
ne craignez pas que ce soit des textes
qui portent un peu à polémiquer vous
préférez éviter cette votre observation
serait juste si ces textes n'étaient pas
passés en conseil des ministres comment
vous pouvez proposer cet argument sur un
texte puisqu'on fait référence à la loi
pénale par exemple qui est passé en
conseil des ministres il ya plusieurs
semaines maintenant ce texte il est
connu si quelqu'un veut utiliser ce
texte dans la campagne des élections
municipales
nous sommes complètement transparent le
texte c'est-à-dire le la position du
gouvernement elle est pas caché c'est
exactement les verts sz
nous avons passé le texte en conseil des
ministres votre argument aurait quelque
force si on avait dit pourra pas dire ce
qu'on veut faire
on le dira après les élections
municipales on a dit depuis plusieurs
semaines ce qu'on allait faire bon
pendant ce temps là on peut observer
marine le pen qui on engrange qui sur
l'écotaxe par exemple elle reçoit l on
voit le ps et l'ump dos à dos est-ce que
ça va continuer pendant longtemps est ce
qu'on va réussir est ce que vous allez
réussir à l'arrêter est-ce qu'on va
réussir et ce que la france va réussir à
l'arrêter au fond c'est vrai que la
montée au moins dans les sondages du
front national aujourd'hui c'est une
source d'inquiétude
et en même temps il faut qu'on parle aux
gens au fond on sait très bien c'est pas
nouveau que l'extrême droite sauf
toujours sur la crise que ce soit la
crise économique que la crise sociale
mais il ya aussi des éléments ils sont
beaucoup plus inquiétant si ce qui
génère aujourd'hui la montée éventuelle
du front national c'est la montée du
rejet de l'autre
c'est une une fracture de la france le
rejet de l'autre qui a changé d'ailleurs
au cours des siècles avant c'était les
juifs maintenant ça semble être plutôt
les les arabes c'est la république qui
est en poste et en même temps je me dis
que si les gens prennent le temps de
réfléchir qu'est ce qu'elle propose
au fond une petite france une france qui
a peur de tout avec un projet économique
qui correspondent à cette idée là c'est
à dire que on va s'enfermer dans nos
frontières
est-ce qu' un seul électeur qui pensent
aujourd'hui que la france irait mieux si
on fermait si la france fermé ses
frontières et alors et des centaines de
milliers de salariés qui travaillent et
chez airbus pour vendre des avions on va
faire quoi on aura tous nos avions pour
nous ça n'a aucun sens sortir de l'euro
avec la dette qui exploserait
immédiatement sanaa ça n'a aucun sens
personne ne peut croire à ça et je pense
je me dis que finalement ce que ce qu'on
a mieux à dire assez aux gens qui sont
tentés par ce vote là c'est à dire est
ce que vous voulez de cette france là
pour vos enfants et je pense que non je
pense que sur le moment ils sont comme
ça peut-être séduit par le fait qu'on a
tout essayé que bon ça va mal mais en
même temps et cette france cette petite
france n'a c'est pas la france quand ils
veulent pour leurs enfants et je crois
que ça c'est un combat frontal c'est le
combat pour la vie
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure que
christiane taubira et la recherche d'un
texte équilibré sur la justice 1
il ya quelques semaines à votre classe
il y avait
gérard longuet qui estime lui que le
carburant du front national c'est
christiane taubira et il nous l'a
déclaré une audi c'est christiane
taubira qui fait le front national que
répondez vous à cela ben je réponds que
quand on s'interroge nous aujourd'hui
sur la porosité entre l'ump et le front
national monsieur longueil ces propos
sont un très bon exemple je veux ajouter
quelque chose qui rejoint un peu votre
question et qui m'étonne au fond il
s'est passé des choses ces dernières 72
heures les événements que vous avez
commenté les uns et les autres
pourquoi est ce que dans l'actualité des
événements les plus graves n'a pas été à
la une
moi ça me révulse que des enfants
accueillent christiane taubira avec des
bananes en faisant le cri de la guenon
il ya des gens en france qui dresse des
enfants à faire ça et ce qui est très
étonnant c'est que ce n'est pas fait la
une de l'actualité est ce que c'est pas
aussi grave que les autres débats qu'on
a qu'on a eue ce week-end et voyez ce
qui m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est que justement cet événement là
était d'une certaine façon pas
totalement mais banalisés alors que
c'est une gravité extrême ont fait leur
rappeler effectivement mais là vous
parlez d'une instrumentalisation de
cette enfant une manipulation de
l'enfant je ne crois pas qu'ils aient
des enfants qui spontanément prennent
des bananes pour aller faire le cri de
la guenon quand ils voient une ministre
quand cristiano ne vous contentez pas
évidemment des dénégations de la manif
pour tous qui a condamné ce fait
lamentable en disant nous n'y sommes
pour rien c'est en dehors de notre code
je ne sais pas qui est responsable mais
dans tous les cas il ya des gens qui
sont responsables de ça et je crois que
mettre cet événement avec sa gravité
dans le débat public aujourd'hui ça me
paraît essentielle pour les municipales
est ce que ce ne sont pas non plus des
élections en risque pour la gauche par
exemple la bretagne actuellement qui est
un peu au yen j'écris et pourtant
énormément de municipalités sont bien
ancrées à gauche et lorsque risque pas
d'y avoir un basculement
je pense que le mieux qu'on ait à faire
quand on affronte une élection c'est de
l'affronter sans aucune certitude
et plus on affronte les élections avec
la crainte plus on est déterminés
justement le vc crainte donc je partage
votre analyse tombe sous le coup du sens
et en même temps je crois que ça doit
renforcer justement et la détermination
des socialistes de la majorité les
majorités municipales dans leur ensemble
de mener ce combat france face aux
français ce qu'il faut pas comment un
électrochoc pour la question viennent de
m'être posé je pense que tu es très
spécifique en plein remaniement
compterait deux poids lourds du ps
la seule chose qui est sûre je sais que
c'est ça passionne c'est bien demain les
commentateurs la seule chose qui est
sûre c'est que le remaniement aura lieu
un jour voilà vous savez bien que le
reste personne n'en sait rien que les
conditions et c'est bien comme ça c'est
président de la république estime s'il
doit le faire ou pas et que personne n'a
d'information et ça me paraît pas être
aujourd'hui complètement à l'ordre du
jour portant je n'en sais strictement
rien donc je veux rien dire là-dessus
donc vous ne suivez pas marie noëlle
lienemann quand elle propose un
changement de cap avec les communistes
août et baryton al-iman elle a le droit
de s'exprimer
c'est une parole forte là j'étais plutôt
d'accord avec est d'ailleurs sur la
réaction qu'elle faisait vis-à-vis des
élus quitté le parti en disant que celle
inverse de la politique d c'est une
démarche personnelle mais je suis
comprenez quand même certaines critiques
vers la démarche
voilà c'est une voie aujourd'hui au
parti socialiste qui est minoritaire et
donc ne peut pas porter ligne du parti
socialiste c'est clair alors à proposer
les cretons on en a parlé effectivement
les hypothèses de rémy mais il aura lieu
mais on ne sait pas quand un jour
forcément dit un jour ça veut dire c'est
forcément vous finirez par avoir raison
même si certains évoquent même et on
laissa
certaines primes et une dissolution qui
aurait l avantage pour françois hollande
de se retrouver en président de
cohabitation et d'avoir de meilleures
chansons en 2017
je pense que ceux qui écrivent ça j'ai
lu ça comme vous y avez vraiment être en
panne sèche seule idée pour pouvoir
remplir du papier je dois dire que là
pour le coup ça me paraît quand même ces
singuliers comme analyse mais bon il ya
des week-ends où on n'est pas inspiré
probablement merci jean louis perrine
tarneaud arrive juste avant l'évocation
de ce débat ce choc qui oppose deux
gauches apparemment françois hollande
était dans une posture d'équilibrisme on
en a parlé il ya un instant entre
idéalisme et réalisme est incarnée par
celui qui connaît une embellie constante
dans les sondages lui au moins c'est
manuel valls françois moulin dans la
guerre des gauches c'est le camp de
manuel valls qui demeure même si
l'affairé honnart d'art a quelque peu
égratigné sa popularité au sein du parti
il reste le ministre le plus apprécié
des sympathisants socialistes
en face la gauche du ps peine à faire
entendre sa voix celle qui dénonce une
droitisation idéologique
cette gauche qui gouverne et qui se dit
moderniste c'est sociaux libéraux à la
française estiment être l'avenir du
parti face aux vieilles lunes et
archaïsme socialiste veut dire c'est
presque une vérité d'évidence que de
dire que ce sont ceux qui gouvernent qui
s'impose parce que sont eux quand même
qui ont la légitimité populaire par
l'expérience c'est par la pratique
gouvernementale que la gauche progresse
se modernise et répond aux attentes des
français que cette gauche là se
prétendent moderne fait bondir les plus
à gauche du ps
très critique envers les récentes
actions du gouvernement et notamment en
matière d'immigration et de sécurité
la sphère léonard d'ajustement a ravivé
les fractures de l'organisme on a mieux
ceux qui veulent le progrès ceux qui
voient le social et se paie veut
partager les richesses talent qui
veulent réduire les inégalités sont
toujours moderne parlée par les aboyeurs
parlait pas les gens qui vous qui vous
prennent le petit la petite fille a
sorti de l'école par les gens qui vous
font un discours sur les migrants
d'origine européenne d'insérer les
appelle comme ça moi je dis pas que
c'était des gens qui n'ont pas à
s'insérer salariale modèle
ces très vieux le conflit n'est pas prêt
de s'apaiser d'autant que le président
de la république donne des gages aux uns
et aux autres et tente une politique
d'équilibriste les positions du ministre
de l'intérieur hystérise de plus en plus
ses opposants la source de la division
s'est lui hurlait socialiste de
l'ancienne école n'était ce pas lui qui
voulait tout remettre en cause au sein
du parti jusqu'à son nom nous a rejoints
en question au ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement
c'est la guerre des modernes contre les
anciens relancer au sein du parti
socialiste et idéologique qui
s'affrontent
oui il ya beau y est il ya des mots sur
les modernes et les anciens je pense que
si on veut faire un effort de
clarification
je dirais que il sait pas les sociaux
libéraux qui dirige aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste et que ce sont ceux qui au
fond s'affiche délibérément comme des
sociaux démocrates avec une fille qui
dirige la france
il érige la france et le parti s'est
dissocié vous avez situer le
le débat l'interlocuteur sans forcément
des socialistes le gouvernement il par
enfant je pense que nous sommes les
sociaux démocrates moderne et qu' il ya
tout à construire et que effectivement
certains de sa démocratie assumer
totalement mais ça veut dire quoi la
social démocratie c'est quelque chose
d'assez clair la social démocratie c'est
cette idée que d'abord nous sommes dans
une économie de marché
soyons terre même si c'est un peu
basique ce que je vais dire ne semble
pas que des gens peut-être quelques
heures mais pas de ceux là pensent qu'il
faut nationaliser tout l'économie et que
notre modèle se serait cuba ou la corée
du nord je crois pas il ya des
entreprises dans un pays et que un
gouvernement de gauche se donne pour
mission de dire ya la situation des
entreprises car on ne peut pas faire
comme si elle n'existait pas ou ne pas
se dire qu'elles sont là pour créer des
richesses d'où ce qui a été fait et en
même temps il ya la situation des
salariés à la question des services
publics n'étaient plus à les joindre la
fiscalité sont invités le pacte de
compétitivité vous savez on peut nous
dire tout ce qu'on veut alors au
détriment des ménages non c'est l'argent
public qui sert à alléger le coût du
travail puisque au fond c'est un
français s'approchaient du mais vous
savez mais vous savez ce qui était
intéressant
il ya eu débat budgétaire il y avait un
autre projet l'ump a élaboré un contre
projet le président de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale a dit
mais voilà ce qu'on ferait nous mais
c'est extrêmement intéressant parce que
si certains se posent la question de
savoir quelle est la différence entre la
droite et la gauche alors moi je les
renvoie ça puisque la réponse est à bah
oui on va faire des économies alors on
va commencer par gelé les salaires des
fonctionnaires par gelé les pensions pas
remettre en cause
quinze mille de suppressions de postes
de fonctionnaires de tous les emprunts
bon c'est la vraie droite et ceux qui se
posent ces questions là y compris marino
à lima je les renvoie s'annonce et un
gouvernement de gauche qui est au
pouvoir dans la cacophonie
actuel on peut se demander si le
gouvernement n'a pas grillé ses
dernières cartouches pour apparaître
comme un parti de gouvernement crédible
ça peut être votre votre appréciation
mais je vais signer devenir convaincre
durci au fil de l'eau y compris celle de
gauche et au fil de l'eau au fil de
l'eau et et au quotidien quand on est
quand on est né des premiers résultats
ne sont pas là mais enfin il ya une
logique et une cohérence dans la
politique ont amené qu'on a menées
depuis le début ça qui est essentiel
c'est quand même ça qui est essentiel
sur des fondements politiques qui sont
majeurs premièrement est ce que ce pays
doit retrouver son indépendance sa
souveraineté ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le politique puisse
encore qu'elle vous faire quelque chose
hélas la situation contre ou avec un
endettement majeur fait section chacun
l'a bien vu les agences de notation qui
décidez donc il faut se désendetter et
il faut réduire le déficit c'est pas le
choix idéologique c'est un passage
obligé pour le retour à la démocratie
c'est quand même fondamental ça c'est ce
que ce gouvernement a fait ensuite
enfin jusqu'au bout voit quand même pour
le désinfectant de la france n'en
attendait oui elle avait raison la tâche
prendrait sont d'après ce qu'on nous a
laissé ma faim vous pouvez pas contester
que on a conçu et commencer à réduire
les déficits et bon c'est quand même
essentiel ça fait 18 mois que nous
sommes là donc c'est ce que nous avons
engagé comme un accord ce gouvernement
en même temps a dit nous allons mettre
la priorité sur ce qui nous gens de
gauche nous importe l'école enfin bien
sûr on parle pas des trains qui arrivent
à l'heure de la rentrée scolaire a quand
même été il ya des nids à des jo il ya
des enseignants contestation quand même
sur l'application de l'année scolaire
oui mais sur les postes d'enseignants
auprès des enfants
les postes qui ont été créés c'était un
choix politique ils sont là et ça ça me
paraît tellement essentielle comment
vous expliquer alors qu'ils aient autant
de critiques contre l'exécutif qu'est-ce
qui tourne pas rond
c'est un problème de communication pas
seulement
vous savez il n'ya pas de nom s'est
jamais la faute des hommes c'est
toujours notre faute
quel est votre monnaie mais parce que
probablement il ya une impatients et la
fracture est forte aussi les difficultés
sociales sont majeurs mais c'est en ce
moment ça atteint sa atteint toujours
les critiques mais il se doit à rien
altéré notre détermination
et vous quand on croit non non non on
croit à ce qu'on fait et on a une
légitimité pour le faire
la seule possible l'élection du peuple
et en même temps mais en même temps on
le lui reproche
le président de la république à cette
méthode qui est la sienne et je l ai dit
tout à l'heure
et quand il rapproche effectivement de
courage du dialogue dans une société qui
est aussi fracturé ça me paraît pour moi
au moins aussi les notables que la
brutalité est ce qu'il ya un problème
dans l'entourage du président la
république dans l'organisation de
l'elysée est ce qu'il faudra
restructurer un petit peu ce qu'est venu
présent la république
j'en sais j'en sais strictement rien et
dans tous les cas ce que je vis au
quotidien pour être l'interlocuteur ses
proches dd non le problème il est pas de
cette nature le problème il est français
ouais mais les français la vie
quotidienne est difficile la vie
quotidienne est difficile ils ont envie
que leur vie quotidienne s'améliore
quand le chômage s'améliore mais ça
continue il ya m 5000 chômeurs de plus
dire il y voit quand même quand même
c'est que les français ne font plus
confiance à françois hollande mais que
le seul les français autant d'attention
qu'il s'en tire dans ce gouvernement
c'est manuel valls regardez les
dernières sont là j'invite d'alice il
fait partie de l'équipe très heureux que
ça sonne son action sur les français
seraient même un meilleur candidat à la
présidentielle que françois hollande moi
je veux pas je veux dire le sait très
bien que la la la la la politique
politicienne les sondages se succèdent
ça n'a strictement aucun intérêt c'est
un 2010 était un président dans
l'opinion aujourd'hui
ce chiffre est en fait votre travail
mais ça n'a aucun intérêt pour l'avenir
pour l'avenir de la france qu'un intérêt
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement d'avoir
dans l'équipe des jeunes des ministres
des réalités dans manuel valls qui je
crois en plus je veux le dire parce que
je partage cette conviction avec lui son
son discours républicain son attachement
aux valeurs républicaines
c'est un rap un rempart essentiel contre
la montée du front national et toute
l'équipe bénéficie de ce positionnement
parce que c'est aussi le nôtre il
l'exprima l'état y compris les essais la
politique politicienne mais on a parlé
tout à l'heure de la cote d' alerte n'a
de l'impopularité du chef de l'état et
certains s'interrogent d'ores et déjà
sur son procès en légitimité
que répondez vous la parole et livre des
gens peuvent peuvent s'interroger
vous savez je regardais bons sondages
sont pas bons mais enfin il ya eu
d'autres périodes où au lieu d'être à
26,6 était à 31
oui est-ce que la différence entre
l'illégitimité la légitimité cédé cinq
points entre 26 et 31 mois je vous
laisse la responsabilité de cette
approche le premier ministre et le
présent à publics ont quand même été
sifflé par exemple à marseille 1 au
lendemain du second tour de la primaire
ps par des militants socialistes
ça vous interpelle pas ça vous gêne pas
mais franchement vous pouvez comme
s'additionner va bien mais je vous dis
pas que tout va bien mais je dire entre
les qu'une des choses et le fond de ce
que vivent les français
je pense qu'il ya une différence c'est
que on peut on doit entendre ce que ça
les questions de fond que se posent les
français
alors est-ce qu'au parti socialiste dans
l'organisation du parti social et c'est
ce que tout va bien
harlem désir dont on dit qu'il est en
sursis est ce qu'il doit partir après
les municipales ou après les ans ne font
pas la même réponse que sur l'elysée un
homme parti socialiste pourquoi sur
l'organisation de la 10è critiqué les
critiques contre contrôler les désirs
mais globalement le parti socialiste a
un problème
et puis c'est pas un problème de
personne c'est un problème est assez
redondant
quel est le positionnement d'un parti
politique lorsque il soutient il
soutient le gouvernement reste toujours
dit
c'est extrêmement difficile et ce
positionnement est pas facile mais c'est
comme ça alain vidalis d'entendre le
chef de ce parti politique au pouvoir
critiquer son président de la république
à peine deux heures après une
intervention à la télévision je parle de
la sphère leone a été la meilleure de
ses interventions mais elle est assez
isolée
enfin il a creusé sa tombe là non alem
désir pourquoi voulez-vous non il a
l'air d'aller bien d'accord j'ai pas vu
bon ok merci des questions de
commentaires je vous ai dit ce que je
pensais de son intervention c'est
d'accord justement dans la sphère
leonarda la famille du bras ni a déposé
un recours pour un éventuel recours
un retour elle pourrait revenir vous
pensez cela la famille dès mardi la
famille de léonard d'ajouter nous sommes
dans un état de droit il aborde c'est
l'honneur de ce pays il ya des lois et
s'il ya des recours qui sont engagés
petites connaissances juridiques il nous
paraît quand même que ce recours la qui
ne serait que le énième il est quand
même extrêmement aléatoires et
probablement vouée à l'échec
vous avez des arguments mis en avant par
cet avocat peut ensemble est réservé
mais je veux pas me substituer au juge
et surtout pas l'exécutif et s'est dès
lors qu'elle juge est saisi c'est lui
qui appréciera et c'est bien comme ça
d'accord est ce que vous redoutez de
nouvelles manifestations de lycéens à la
rentrée après les vacances de la
toussaint on voit pas très bien quelle
serait quel serait le le fondement
voilà il ya une proposition qui a été
fait l'a été suffisamment critiqué par
le président la république a souhaité à
la fois rappelé la règle de droit et le
respect des décisions de justice et
avoir un geste puisqu'il y avait eu un
dysfonctionnement
vous pensez que sa nature à calmer les
lycéens même s'ils sont encouragés par
votre ami un jean vincent placé
oui c'est je lui réserverez là sur cette
affaire la même observation que
précédemment jeu
connue mais hier dans ses interventions
que celle là c'est tout ce soft
il appelle quand même des lycéens à
descendre dans la rue je compte en ce
moment c'est pas la meilleure de ses
interventions c'est clair le budget de
la sécurité sociale a été adoptée tout à
l'heure par l'assemblée nationale avec
le volet parc donc en sursis
est-ce que les modifications vont être
apportées j'imagine ici au sénat lors de
la lecture au sénat
ça va être quoi par quel biais par des
amendements du gouvernement par des
amendements du rapporteur
vous avez fait la question les
amendements du par les amendements du
gouvernement
j'ajoute simplement que le texte a été
voté tout à l'heure à l'assemblée
nationale par 320 voix contre 243 et ce
qui est important par rapport à la
majorité que l'on divisé c'est que sur
les questions essentielles
la loi de finances non l'autre finances
du pays le budget la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale
l'ensemble des partis membres de la
majorité se sont rassemblés à
l'assemblée nationale
dernière question très rapidement sur le
travail du dimanche est une décision
aujourd'hui la cour d'appel de paris qui
autorise castorama et leroy merlin à
rouvrir mais par bricorama on est
complètement perdue est ce qu'il va y
avoir une loi sur le travail du dimanche
qui va simplifier tout ça il y aura
peut-être une fois la décision n'est pas
prise en tant est qu'il y aura un
dispositif juridique nouveau vous le
savez la décision qui a été prise c'est
de confier à monsieur il ya eu une étude
sur ces questions là avec les problèmes
éventuellement d'ajustement parce que je
partage votre votre appréciation sur le
cac est assez difficilement
compréhensible aussi pathétiques et la
justice mais il me semble qu'il ya pas
forcément de logique dans les décisions
successives mais peut-être qu'on n'a pas
tous les éléments
dans tous les cas il faut enfin vous
avez quelle est votre position sur la
décision de justice en appel une
autorisation est donnée mais ils n'ont
respecté décision de l'uci il ya une
règle de droit aujourd'hui cette règle
de droit manifestement est assez ambiguë
elle aboutit à des effusions peut-être
une loi si c'est nécessaire mais c'est
pourquoi je dis ça c'est pas pour
échapper à la question c'est que pour
rentrer dans un débat plus juridique
probablement p6 à des modifications
elles peuvent aussi intervenir
simplement par décret
moi je remercie c'est pas trop dur de
monter au front pour défendre le
gouvernement auquel vous avez vous
appartenez vous parler du courage du
chef de l'état il vous en faut j'en suis
je suis très heureux j'en suis très
heureux et au contraire voilà au
contraire je suis très content de venir
du mandat comme gouverneur ça me fait
merci plaisir et merci et merci à vous
et je reviendrai autant protégé merci
bonsoir à tous et à très vite
que